Olá vivemos tempos em que economizar é
essencial mas sem jamais comprometer a
qualidade do Cuidado Com a nossa saúde e
é exatamente isso que vamos abordar
nesse vídeo soluções práticas naturais e
surpreendentemente econômicas para
cuidar da sua saúde eu estarei
compartilhando com vocês seis remédios
naturais poderosos e aliados na promoção
da saúde e prevenção de doenças e o mais
incrível sem exigir grandes
investimentos financeiros como médico
entendo profundamente os desafios que
enfrentamos no cotidiano sejam eles
relacionados à saúde ou orçamento
doméstico por isso dediquei tempo e
pesquisa para trazer a vocês opções
valiosas com eficácia e acessibilidade
Então vamos falar sobre um remédio
natural incrível que é barato fácil de
encontrar e que tem muitos benefícios o
limão pessoal não subestime o limão
primeiramente é uma fonte rica de
vitamina C pot áo e outros minerais
essenciais o que faz dele um forte
aliado do nosso sistema de defesa
sistema imune ou imunológico beber água
com limão regularmente pode ajudar a
fortalecer nossas defesas naturais
prevenindo gripes e resfriados um limão
fresco oferece quase metade da vitamina
C que precisamos por dia o limão não é
apenas bom pra imunidade ele também
ajuda na digestão reduz a gordura no
fígado e pode até auxiliar na perda de
peso como parte de uma dieta equilibrada
e também de exercícios os seus
fitonutrientes como a naringina tem
propriedades antibacterianas e
antivirais e estão sendo estudados até
para tratamento de doenças como é o caso
do Doença de Alzheimer outra
característica interessante do limão é
seu efeito diurético ele ajuda na
eliminação de toxinas mantendo o nosso
trato urinário saudável e promovendo uma
desintoxicação natural do corpo e
falando em digestão o limão mão estimula
também a produção de enzimas digestivas
isso Vai facilitar o quê a quebra de
gorduras e melhorar a digestão para quem
se preocupa com a saúde do coração a
água com limão pode ser um grande aliado
ela ajuda na prevenção de doenças
cardiovasculares controlando a pressão
arterial e promovendo a saúde das
artérias pessoal o limão possui citrato
que pode prevenir e combater pedra nos
rins mas escolha bem o seu limão prefiro
os orgânicos com casca fina brilhante e
Lisa que são mais suculentos
você é novo por aqui clique em
inscrever-se e entre para a nossa turma
saudável curtiu o vídeo então dê um
joinha e não guarde essas dicas só para
você compartilhe nas suas redes sociais
no WhatsApp com seus amigos e parentes
spal saúde e informação de qualidade
nosso segundo remédio natural gengibre
ele é rico em compostos como gingerol
que possuem propriedades antioxidantes
antiinflamatórias ele é conhecido por
suas propriedades antieméticas que faz
facilita o esvaziamento do estômago
prevenindo o refluxo e má digestão por
isso um chazinho de gengibre antes ou
depois das refeições pode ajudar quem
sofre com problemas digestórios o
gengibre é um excelente remédio natural
para náuseas e vômitos sendo seguro até
mesmo para gestantes Além disso ele é um
aliado contra infecções fúngicas e
bacterianas incluindo aquelas que afetam
o trato urinário pessoal essa raiz
também tem ação anti inflamatória sendo
benéfica no alívio de dores musculares
menstruais e nas articulações como as
causadas por artrite reumatismo e
artrose o gengibre tem um papel Vital na
prevenção de doenças cardiovasculares
graças à sua capacidade de inibir a
formação de placas de gordura nos vasos
sanguíneos e melhorar a circulação agora
como você pode incorporar o gengibre na
sua rotina uma ótima maneira é a água
com gengibre escolha raízes com casca
fina e brilhante corte em fatias finas e
adicione a duas xícaras de água quente
ou morna deixe descansar por 10 minutos
coe e consuma como preferir Você pode
adicionar limão açafrão casca de abacaxi
ou canela para potencializar os
benefícios continuando nossa jornada
pelos remédios naturais Vamos agora
falar sobre o ingrediente que muitos de
vocês já conhecem e usam na cozinha que
é o alho um de seus componentes mais
notáveis é a alicina que traz aquele
aroma característico do áo é a chave
para muitos seus efeitos benéficos a
alicina ajuda a proteger os órgãos de
toxinas e metais tóxicos ela protege o
sistema de defesa imune de substâncias
químicas que são pesticidas agrotóxicos
usados na
agropecuária assim quando você come áo
você limpa seu corpo e faz um detox
dessas toxinas que são muito nocivas pra
sua imunidade agora pessoal sem dúvida
um dos benefícios mais conhecidos e
utilizados do áo é a sua proteção contra
infecções e melhora da imunidade o áo
contém composto com propriedades
antimicrobianas que ajudam a combater e
prevenir doenças ele ainda consegue
proteger o seu organismo contra
parasitas quando falamos de saúde
cardiovascular o áo é muito interessante
ele trabalha para reduzir a pressão
arterial e melhora a circulação
diminuindo o risco de doenças cardíacas
Além disso ele possui propriedades
antiagregantes que podem reduzir o risco
de coágulo sanguíneo de trombose para
consumir o alho da melhor maneira
escolha variedades orgânicas e locais de
preferência com a casca roxa ou Rosada
um a dois dentes de alho por dia
preferencialmente cru são suficientes
para aproveitar os seus benefícios
lembre-se de picar moer ou ralar o alho
e deixá-lo descansar por alguns minutos
antes de usar para potencializar a
alicina também Recomendo o alho
fermentado ou uso da água de alho a
nossa comunidade de membros que tira
dúvidas comigo diretamente em lives
semanais já aprendeu muito sobre saúde
conheça esse e outros benefícios basta
clicar embaixo Aqui no botão seja membro
avançando em nossa lista de remédios
naturais eu vou falar agora sobre algo
que pode surpreender a água com sal
integral quem acompanha o canal já sabe
sobre isso esse simples remédio natural
quando feito com tipo certo de sal pode
trazer uma série de benefícios pra saúde
entre suas várias funções o sal integral
atua transportando vitamina C
diretamente paraa nossas células
desempenha um papel interessante na
regulação da glicose ajuda a prevenir a
osteoporose e até potencializa a conexão
elétrica entre nosso cérebro e células
nervosas pessoal diferente do sal de
mesa comum que é altamente refinado o
sol integral ele mantém uma riqueza de
minerais que são todos essenciais essa
variedade de sal não refinado é uma
fonte natural de eletrólitos como é o
caso do sódio do potássio cálcio e
magnésio que são fundamentais para a
nossa hidratação e saúde geral beber
água com sal integral pode ser uma forma
eficaz de começar o dia ajudando na
digestão e fornecendo um impulso de
energia Além disso pode ser um ótimo
remédio para dores musculares até mesmo
câimbras e auxiliar saúde pulmonar agora
um momento especial para quem sofre com
problemas respiratórios ou alergias o
sal integral ajuda ele atua como
antibacteriano antiinflamatório ajudando
a limpar as vias aéreas eliminando o
muco e combatendo alergias e aliviando a
sinusite e se por acaso a sua garganta
estiver incomodando por causa de algum
vírus ou bactéria um simples gargarejo
com água morna e sal integral pode ser
um verdadeiro alívio para você um dos
grandes benefícios da água com sal
integral é a ativação de enzimas
essenciais paraa digestão e absorção de
nutrientes ela também fundamental na
produção de ácido clorídrico no estômago
isso vai melhorar a função digestória e
vai ajudar a combater a constipação ela
também pode ajudar a regular os
hormônios do estresse e melhorar a
qualidade do Sono além de ser crucial
paraa função da tireoide e é
interessante notar que apesar das
preocupações com a pressão alta com
hipertensão o sal integral quando usado
com moderação pode ajudar a equilibrar
os níveis de
sódio Diferentemente do sal refinado
comum de mesa que vai piorar a situação
para preparar sua água com sal integral
simplesmente adicione uma pequena colher
de sal integral colher de café a 2 l de
água beba um pouco dessa água em jejum
pela manhã e distribua o restante ao
longo do dia mas como sempre essencial
equilíbrio e moderação se você tem
condições pré-existentes como doenças
cardíacas ou renais consulte seu médico
antes de adotar essa prática pessoal o
vinagre de maçã obtido através da
fermentação do suco de maçãs é um
verdadeiro elixi de saúde por isso ele
não pode faltar na Nosa lista para
garantir que você aproveite todos os
benefícios é fundamental escolher o
vinagre de maçã orgânico e não pauster
consumir vinagre de maçã diluído em água
pela manhã em jejum pode ajudar a
estimular o sistema digestório atuando
como um detox suave a pectina que é uma
fibra solúvel presente na maçã ajuda na
saúde intestinal e Combate o intestino
preso para quem sofre de refluxo ácido o
vinagre de maçã pode ser
surpreendentemente benéfico ao contrário
da crença Popular o refluxo muitas vezes
é causado por baixa acidez no estômago
ao invés de alta consumir uma uma colher
de sopa de vinagre de maçã em um copo de
água Antes das refeições pode ajudar a
equilibrar essa
acidez outro benefício incrível do
vinagre de maçã é a sua capacidade de
ajudar no controle do açúcar do sangue
beber vinagre de maçã diluído antes de
uma refeição rica em carboidratos pode
reduzir os Picos de açúcar no sangue
sendo especialmente útil para pessoas
que tem diabetes ou pré-diabetes ou
mesmo resistência à insulina e Que tal o
vinagre de maçã antes de dormir isso
pode ajudar a regular os níveis de
glicose durante a noite prevenindo Picos
e quedas que podem perturbar o seu sono
mas atenção é importante começar com uma
quantidade pequena e aumentar
gradualmente aos poucos o consumo
exagerado de vinagre de maçã pode levar
a desconfortos ou até problemas de saúde
pessoas com doenças renais crônicas ou
problemas estomacais como é o caso de
úlceras E gastrite deve ter especial
cautela ou evitar o consumo ou mesmo só
consumir Com acompanhamento pessoal
existe um produto incrível que apesar de
não ser o mais barato na nossa lista é
um verdadeiro tesouro paraa saúde que
Todos deveriam ter em casa própolis de
abelha própolis é uma mistura de resina
produzida pelas abelhas combinando sua
saliva e cera com substâncias coletadas
de broos de árvore seiva e outras fontes
botânicas essa substância é usada pelas
abelhas para proteger a comeia contra
microorganismos mas também oferece uma
série de benefícios pra saúde humana a
própolis brasileira é especialmente
celebrada por sua composição química
distinta e é considerada uma das
melhores do mundo existe diferentes
tipos de própolis Cada uma com suas
indicações específicas a própolis marrom
por exemplo é excelente para dor de
garganta resfriados e uso tópico como
antisséptico e cicatrizante feridas a
própolis vermelha é conhecida por suas
propriedades antioxidantes sendo
utilizada também cremes de beleza no
combate a parasitas como giardia e
bactérias e por suação de falatória já a
própolis verde é famosa por suas
propriedades contra fungos e bactérias
no auxílio da função renal no controle
do herpes um tratamento de gripes
resfriados e até at toa contra o câncer
pessoal a própolis verde é fantástica
como imunomoduladora ou seja atuando
diretamente no sistema de defesa imune
de forma a fortalecer suas defesas e se
seu funcionamento todos esses remos
naturais que eu falei eu tenho um vídeo
inteiro e completo dedicado a cada um
deles onde eu explico como utilizar eu
vou deixar os links na descrição todos
esses links estão disponíveis ali
portanto se você quer se aprofundar Em
Algum deles é só clicar no link e
aproveitar toda a riqueza de informações
Muito obrigado pela sua atenção um
grande abraço um beijo no seu coração
você é
feira